so is it true that you recently said
that Chris is is who you want to be when
you grow up
you can say it in front of them you're
embarrassing
man Chris is a great guy with a real
integrity and he's brilliant and he's a
great dad and he's just a and also he
knows everybody like I'm not even
kidding you can bring up a name it
doesn't matter if it's like Muhammad Ali
Paul McCartney Jesus
yeah that's my boy I'm like what do you
mean that's your boy how do you know
like I don't even know Michael Jordan I
was like there's this guy Howard white
who works at you I know Howard white
he's my friend I'll be like this is an
unbelievable
you don't know you know everybody I kind
of do you know
I mean Ben and my buddy Davis repel they
always joke you know everybody man
you're everywhere where are you right
now I'm like I'm in Saudi Arabia with
the King I'll be right back he's giving
gifts away he's giving gifts away it's
just Oprah's Favorite Things
okay how about like Stevie Wonder You
Know Stevie Wonder I know Stevie
Stevie's oh man he calls keep trying
you're gonna have to go way deeper than
Stevie Wonder I thought it was gonna be
cool because he handed me my first
Grammy so I was gonna be like my story
is pretty good Chris oh yeah no but you
know I was like you know Muhammad Ali is
like yeah
he said you're a funny Mother Tucker
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
went to Africa and he was like where is
Chris Tucker
I want him to meet my grandkids
are incredible BB King
he would say hey Chris Bill Russell
people like that I mean it's great to
you know just just meet them incredible
yeah now you know I want to be Chris
Tucker are you the person that can
really remember like I was a waitress so
I feel like I'm really good with faces
but now games I'm always like
interesting yes our faces but not names
yeah you can write you must be
left-handed you use the right side of
you no I'm no I'm right-handed but like
I have horrible handwriting so it
doesn't matter which hand me too me too
yes but no I I literally I can remember
face as well but names I'm always like
you yeah oh yeah yeah you do the like
nice to see ya yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]